ça va dresser enfants ce moment toi on
parle pas c'est la cata j'en peux plus
je pense que léo nous prend pour des
cons mais vraiment way i les feignants
c'est pas un poil qu'il a dans la main
c'est un baobab
si tu veux mon avis alors je lui ai dit
pourtant fait des fiches révise relie
moi c'est ce que je faisais ça a marché
très très bien alors je comprends pas
alors que s'il faisait des efforts je
suis sûr qu'il y arriverait on sait
comme comme on dit toujours quand on
veut on peut donc finalement ben oui on
voit toute façon attendre c'est leur
truc à la génération x y z là je sais
pas comment il les appelle à tuer ils
disent qu'ils sont pas comme nous oui
comme nous comme nous on était mais
purée quand même il faut qu'ils
comprennent un truc c'est pas un bouffon
des chips sur son canapé en regardant
secretstory qui va la voir son bac quand
même et quand tu vois en plus comme en
galère enfin j'ai pas faudrait être
aveugle et sourd pour pas savoir qu'il
ya du chômage il ya trois millions et
demi chômeurs ça fait peur quand même
ben ouais mais toute façon vous allez
être petit peu obligé de lui apprendre à
souffrir entre guillemets quand même
parce que le patron lui il n'ya pas lui
faire de cadeaux tf comment il a galéré
benoît pour son poste de directeur c'est
des requins il faut avoir les dents
hyper longue pour majeur c'est comme toi
les enfants comment ça va n'ont pas mis
au point ses katas floral vient de
rentrer en seconde
je crois qu'elle n'a pas compris que
c'était hyper important alors tu dois se
fait une petite moyenne en maths mais un
trou un petit truc tu as un 14,25 casse
pas des briques est pour aller en s
ça va être l'horreur donc
je sais plus quoi faire quand elle veut
aller en s ah bah non mais ça j'en sais
rien de toute façon c'est la voie royale
elle peut pas choisir une autre filière
d'abord son père en frais de maladie
c'est tous des matheux dans la famille
puis est ce ça ouvre toutes les portes
ah bah ça c'est sûr ça vous fait toutes
les portes et puis en plus forte qu'elle
comprenne que si elle baisse mais elle
va finir en l ou en bep
non mais non on ne m'en parle pas on ne
m'en parle pas et puis il ya quand même
un truc avec tout le fric qu'on dépense
en soutien scolaire
il manquerait plus qu'ils aient pas de
résultats non plus toute façon
franchement c'est darwin qui avait
raison tuez les plus forts qu'ils s'en
sortent dans la vie alors on préfère
sortir du sketch parce que vous l'avez
compris c'est pour toutes ces raisons là
on a décidé de mettre en oeuvre la
pédagogie positive pour tordre le cou la
à tous ces mythes ses croyances
populaires totalement fausses qui
bousillent des générations d'enfants des
enfants dont la confiance en eux font
comme la calotte glaciaire et dont les
signes de même et dans les chaussettes
et des enfants qui deviennent des
adultes et des adultes qui sont inquiets
qu'ils n'ont pas plus confiance en eux
et qui bat par exemple le travail ont du
mal à donner de nouvelles propositions
alors l'augmentation on vous en parle
même pas qu'ils se mettent une pression
pour être toujours plus à la hauteur et
arriver aux objectifs et qui finalement
est bien perdre le sens de leur travail
de leur activité faute d'avoir la main
dessus et ça c'est moche tu veux dire
c'est très moche c'est très moche et ce
constat il n'est pas très folichon
finalement donc performance obligation
de résultat surcharge d'activité
compétition la pression qu'elle soit
scolaire social professionnel ou
personnel
de toute façon elle a toujours les mêmes
conséquences une baisse de l'estimé de
soi une baisse de la confiance en soi
une chute drastique de la créativité du
courage et de la motivation et ça c'est
le best-of de ce qu'on entend dans nos
cabinets de là
de nos patients ouais parce que pendant
des années ça fait des années qu'on les
suit tous ses petits patients des petits
des moyens et des grands
et qu'on a entendu se crier toute cette
douleur et toute cette souffrance dans
nos cabinets on a vu des parents qui
étaient complètement démunis faute de
pouvoir trouver des solutions pour pour
leurs enfants
on a vu des enfants tellement malheureux
de pas y arriver et culpabilisant en
plus et on a même vu des grands
gaillards pourtant cadres sup
s'effondrer littéralement en plein burn
out
du coup avec ce constat là qui est pas
sexy on peut le dire on est une vraie
question à se poser une question
essentielle qui est sommes nous tous
programmés pour échouer alors on est une
deuxième question parce qu'on aime bien
poser des questions on adore ça même la
deuxième question qu'on va vous posez
vous allez essayer d'y répondre
c'est celle là à votre avis que vaut-il
mieux réussir sa vie ou réussir dans la
vie
alors réussir deux amis qui lève la main
pour réussir sa vie alors réussir dans
la vie
d'accord alors vous on peut dire que
vous êtes un public un peu particulier
si déjà vous venez des conférences ted
c'est que vous questionnez vous
interrogez que vous êtes plutôt ouverts
mais on peut vous dire par expérience
qu'en général la réponse qu'on entend le
plus souvent quand on pose cette
question là c'est assez évident c'est
réussir dans la vie c'est très important
d'avoir de bien travailler à l'école et
ensuite d'avoir un bon métier parce que
c'est ça qui va nous sortir de là et on
pose toujours une autre question encore
de dire mais oui mais à quel prix
à quel prix on va réussir
professionnellement
parce que nous ce qu'on voit c'est que
ça coûte très très cher c'est au prix
très cher payé au niveau financier au
niveau physique et au niveau
psychologique on va prendre un exemple
un peu pour illustrer cela on va prendre
un exemple de réussite scolaire
donc on prend un jeune ou une jeune
brillante brillant bac avec mention très
bien qu'ils intègrent une prépa d'élite
et qui réussit brillamment le concours
des super école polytechnique ou
centrale etc
a priori on est tous d'accord pour dire
qu'il a brillamment réussi
or il a brillamment réussi son parcours
scolaire
qu'est ce qu'on sait de son niveau de
bonheur est-ce qu'on a une idée de son
degré de confiance en lui est ce qu'on
sait même s'il a vraiment choisi lui
tout seul cette voie là ça nous donne en
fait aucun indicateur de son degré de
bien-être physique ou psychologique
oui parce qu'en fait si on y regarde
bien notre système vise à former des
élites intellectuelles mais pas à former
des adultes épanouis créatif inventif et
des adultes qui quelles que soient les
situations vont réussir à s'adapter des
vtt en somme matière justement en
parlant de vtt quand on pose la question
aux enfants de savoir voilà on a
toujours ça va à l'école est gentil ta
maîtresse lors de questions et puis
arrive la question fatidique
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard on
voit jamais posé la question à un enfant
de ce qu'il veut être est-ce qu'il veut
être heureuse qui veut être épanouie est
ce qu il veut être curieux créatif et c
est de la même façon quand on rencontre
des adultes ils vont vous dire bonjour
je suis et derrière il y aura un métier
quand on fait comme si on pouvait pas
exister autrement qu'à travers notre
métier et le diplôme qui va bien il
savait qu'il va bien et donc est ce que
de ceux qui n'ont pas de travail ou qui
n'ont pas encore ou qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des mères au foyer parce que c'est
reconnu comme travail on sait pas
alors du coup si on se place du côté de
réussir sa vie
on voit bien que dans cette notion de
c'est beaucoup plus grand et que ça
dépasse largement la simple question de
la réussite scolaire ou de la réussite
professionnelle
on donne toujours cette image là du du
tabouret à quatre pieds pour expliquer
ce que c'est que réussir sa vie réussir
sa vie c'est réussir à maintenir un
équilibre et un équilibre sur une
globalité la globalité des quatre pieds
ou en fait un des pieds serait le pôle
réussir dans la vie donc
professionnellement scolairement un
autre pied serait le pôle famille un
autre encore serait la relation les
relations sociales et encore un autre
qui serait l'évolution personnelle
on voit bien que sur un tabouret quand
il manque un pied ça tient encore à peu
près ça fait un trépied c'est un peu
fragile mais si en plus ont surinvesti
un des pieds qu'on fait porter une
charge très lourde sur un seul des pieds
comme on le fait tous où beaucoup
d'entre nous sur cette réussite
professionnelle et bien un moment donné
l'équilibré rompu si on prend un autre
exemple c'est un peu comme s'ils ont
décidé de faire paris dunkerque en
marchant mais avec des chaussures bien
trop petite pour nos pieds et qui
n'oublie bien les orteils pour avant je
vous laisse le temps de le sens bien je
peux vous le dire parce que je les ai
mis ce soir faudrait pas que ça dure
trop longtemps on a fait ce matin à pied
et bien cette france là nous on n'est
pas du tout on n'arrive pas à se
résigner
on peut pas accepter du tout du tout
c'est vraiment viscérale que l'école et
le travail soient des lieux de
souffrance parce que ça ça nous est
insupportable et c'est pour lutter
contre ça qu'on se lève tous les matins
de depuis des années pour se mettre
résolument du côté de réussir sa vie
dans une approche globale et
respectueuse et harmonieuse qu'est la
pédagogie positive
du coup la pédagogie positif c'est quoi
alors c'est un parti pris c'est même un
engagement c'est vraiment je vous redis
c'est quelque chose d'assez viscérale
s'est fait rentrer dans de la pédagogie
de la psychologie positive et c'est
choisir la joie et le côté lumineux de
la force
alors on fait un petit point la
psychologie positive pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas qui ne connaîtraient
pas la psychologie positive s'est pas
exactement la même chose que la pensée
positive la pensée positive bien connu
dans un skate je vais bien tout va bien
tout me tout et get to me
tout me plaît la psychologie possible
c'est pas du tout ça c'est se dire que
on a tous les ressources en nous quelles
que soient les situations même les plus
désagréables et les plus difficiles pour
dépasser les difficultés et pour aller
vers une harmonie globale et vert vers
son bonheur et c'est aussi une autre
idée qui nous tient vraiment beaucoup à
coeur toutes les deux je pense que c'est
vraiment notre credo qui est qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité ni dans le malheur ni
dans la souffrance ni dans l'échec
d'ailleurs l'échec n'existe pas il ya
que des tentatives et que des rencontres
qui se sont pas fait mais un jour ça
arrivera en fait la pédagogie positive
c'est se dire que la peur d'échouer la
pression les petites phrases assassines
les petits mots qui tuent la compa
entendent parfois ça fait pas mieux
travailler ça fait même pas bien du tout
travaillé et ça ne nous fait pas bien et
ça ne nous fait pas produire mieux
comprendre qu'on peut faire grandir sa
confiance en soi qu'on peut tordre le
cou la à cette peur d'échouer et que ce
qu'on entend souvent comme critique
quand on dit pédagogie positive c'est un
beau oui d'accord merci laxisme ont fait
rien là c est tranquille et ben non on
fait des efforts mais c'est des efforts
qui vont pas être synonyme de souffrance
c'est des efforts qui vont donner du
résultat et qui ne vont pas nous
bousiller notre confiance en nous et
sting quand même nous mêmes et alors
c'est avec tout ça on a eu envie d'elle
et expérimenté quand même à un moment
donné et donc on est allé tout les deux
expérimentés en tant que psy et en tant
qu'enseignante dans des établissements
scolaires qui accueillait des élèves en
difficulté en grande difficulté qui
présentait des troubles des
apprentissages houde et ou d'ailleurs
des troubles du comportement et en fait
ça a été pendant des années un
merveilleux laboratoire
d'expérimentation une mise en oeuvre
alors par exemple comme pouvoir
introduire au quotidien de la relaxation
sur un groupe classe et de voir ce que
ça donne
organiser des chefs trésor pour
apprendre une leçon d'histoire marie
antoinette en l'occurrence des rigolos
et surtout faire intervenir l'évaluation
une fois que nous étions persuadés que
tous les élèves étaient en situation de
la réussir et ça ça change tout
finalement et en plus ça a marché et on
l'a vu on l'a vu on a vu en quelques
mois
des élèves qui reprenaient confiance en
eux et les résultats sont arrivés
ensuite parce que c'est toujours dans ce
sens là on conquiert d'abord la
confiance en soi l estime de soi sans se
mettre la pression et ensuite les
résultats arrivent naturellement et donc
ça ça nous a confortés toutes les deux
dans l'idée que ce qui fonctionne pour
des enfants d où des adultes même des
apprenants on va dire des travailleurs
qui sont en difficulté a fortiori ça
fonctionne quand il n'y a pas de
difficultés quand tout va bien et du
coup on a mis en place une boîte à
outils là un peu funky comme on aime
donc avec des outils qu'on aime des
approches qu'on aime et surtout des
approches qu'elle en a été formé donc ça
peut être la gestion mentale la thérapie
systémique des outils de pensée visuel
le mind mapping sketch nothing et c'est
l'hypnose
alors pour faire une approche qui soit
vraiment intégrative parce que nous on a
du mal d'appartenir à une seule chapelle
on trouve qu'il ya du bien partout donc
on met ensemble et c'est beaucoup mieux
donc une approche intégrative qui soit
simple et vivante
et puis on a rajouté l'humour de façon
très égoïste parce que nous on déteste
se faire ch
de s'ennuyer au travail et on ya rajouté
aussi ce qu'on appelle l'effet pygmalion
alors on l'entend aussi sous le nom de
prophétie auto-réalisatrice donc les
filles fument à lyon il a été mis en
lumière par un célèbre petit américain
robert rosen talbot pour les intimes et
c'est l'idée que le regard qu'on porte
sur une situation va conditionner
consciemment ou inconsciemment le
résultat attendu est le résultat obtenu
est donc pas par exemple on va vous
donner un exemple de des faits pygmalion
négatif ça marche dans les deux sens un
réel négatif et positif alors exemple
des faits pygmalion négatif si je crois
que cet élève là est complètement débile
et qu'il est déjà en échec parce qu'il
sait pas lire
au bout de trois semaines du cp il y a
de fortes chances que je donne raison à
ma croyance de la même manière que si je
pense que mon collègue à d'autres cuit
tu penses que j'ai depuis maintenant pas
du tout alors l'effet pygmalion ça
s'applique aussi à soi c'est à dire que
si j'ai en tête que travail égal
souffrance puisque travail la racine du
mot travail c'est tripalium objet de
torture donc travail égal souffrance il
ya de fortes chances que j'active ce
schéma là et que je sois persuadé que le
travail c'est long et difficile et je
vais me conformer à ma croyance
alors en plus cette chose là ça ne nous
poursuit jusque dans le travail une fois
qu'on est adulte faut arrêter de croire
que tout ça s'arrête une fois qu'on a
quitté l'école bon la bonne nouvelle
c'est que comme on l'a dit est l'effet
pygmalion positif et ça marche dans le
sens et là on rentre dans un vrai cercle
vertueux et surtout si on ajoute en plus
quelque chose qu'on adore mais vraiment
qu'on attend et qu'on pratique au
quotidien
qui est ce qu'on appelle le renforcement
positif des comportements c'est quoi le
renforcement positif des comportements
c'est vraiment aussi un parti pris c'est
révéler les talents plutôt que de
focaliser sur toujours les défauts et
les faiblesses
s'est focalisé sur ce qui fonctionne
bien
plutôt que de stigmatiser toujours ce
qui fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne
pas et là on rentre dans un vrai cercle
vertueux et tout va beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs si vous utilisez le
renforcement positif avec votre conjoint
il ya vraiment de fortes chances que
vous ayez un massage des pieds tous les
soirs enfin non l'attestait on va tester
à prouver un de notre côté donc emma
quand on a mis trois ans on a mis tout
ça ensemble
effectivement on a mis notre boîte à
outils notre expérience
l'effet pygmalion l'humour on a vu
apparaître un axe une colonne vertébrale
la pédagogie positive qu'on a appelé la
kz tête que record alors comment ça
fonctionnait l'ex take her corps va très
bien merci
bah ça me rassure alors l'extérieur
corps c'est vraiment cette idée que nous
ne sommes pas de simples cerveau sur
deux pattes et c'est prendre en compte
d'abord la tête donc la tête c'est
comprendre mon propre fonctionnement
cognitif et celui de l'autre c'est
prendre en compte le coeur et comprendre
que les émotions font partie intégrante
sont nos alliés et font partie
intégrante de tout apprentissage ou de
tout travail et enfin prendre en compte
ce corps dont on prend pas assez soin
mais on doit vraiment en prendre encore
plus loin parce qu'il ya une réalité
biologique et qu'on a besoin de dormir
suffisamment de s'aérer de manger de
bouger et même de faire pipi
non mais vous rigolez mais nous quand il
intervient dans des entreprises etc on
dit aux gens ce truc là il y en a qui
nous disent ah oui mais c'est vrai ce
que vous dites parce que parfois il ya
des journées bien nous n'avons pas le
temps de faire pipi
on n'a pas le temps de faire de pause
alors justement en parlant de pas le
temps on n'a malheureusement pas le
temps de vous donner tous les exemples
d'enseignants qui ont choisi de faire de
mettre en oeuvre de de prendre la
pédagogie positive et de la mettre en
oeuvre dans leur classe donc ceux qui
choisissent de faire boire leurs élèves
voire de l'eau parce que ils se rendent
compte qu'ils sont plus concentrés de
mettre la relaxation au programme
d'utiliser du mind mapping etc
et puis pas le temps non plus de vous
donner tous les exemples de pédagogie
positive en entreprise on intervient
régulièrement pour se rendre compte que
c'est un vrai outil collaboratif
mais du coup on n'a pas le temps vous
donner ces exemples mais reste posée la
question de savoir pourquoi ça marche
cette méthode là plutôt qu'un de bons
coups de fouet qui est qui faisait bien
la faire il ya encore quelques temps
eh bien pourquoi ça marche c'est parce
qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle l' expérience
optimale qu'est ce que c'est que
l'expérience optimale c'est que quand on
tient la tête le coeur et le corps
ensemble et qu'on sait que les trois
vont être de bons alliés
alors on devient beaucoup plus efficace
et beaucoup plus efficace sans s'épuiser
alors on a une dernière question à vous
poser
pas tout à fait parce que ça nous il ya
quand même une autre question qu'on nous
pose qui et combien ça coûte la
pédagogie positive à votre avis eh ben
ça coûte que dalle ça coûte 00 francs à
mettre en oeuvre parce qu'on a juste à
changer son regard à mettre en place des
choses qui sont vraiment simple du côté
ludique et joyeux
donc voilà peut-être que tu as posé la
fameuse question
ouais dernière question à votre avis
sommes-nous tous programmés pour échouer
merci beaucoup moins fiable